before I met Jonathan In the Flesh I
might have a photograph of Jonathan
there in my living room Jonathan comes
in and he moves into the house I don't
need the photograph you know it's
redundant I've got Jonathan himself and
so there's that it's interesting because
you know I'm so bound up in the question
of symbolism but you in the Orthodox
especially in the Orthodox iconographic
tradition there's a there's some aspect
of it which is you could call
anti-symbolic in the sense that they
they move moving towards saying Christ
is the finality of these images and so
when you have Christ it's the you don't
you're not necessarily wanting to
represent him in these Shadows but you
have the thing itself it doesn't mean
that symbolism doesn't continue to exist
in this typological way there's a sense
in which Christ is the is the end of the
of the symbolic pyramid
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
I'm an associate professor in the
department of practical theology here at
Princeton Theological Seminary I'm also
the founder and executive director of
Scala Foundation which is a non-profit
whose mission is to renew culture
through liberal arts education Beauty
and worship
I'm joining you here today from the
studios at Princeton Theological
Seminary where I have the pleasure of
Hosting Aiden Hart an iconographer born
in England raised in New Zealand now
residing in England that's right and
Jonathan pejo from Quebec Canada who was
also an iconographer and icon Sculptor
both Aiden and Jonathan are here this
weekend for the conference on Art the
common good and the sacred being hosted
by Scala and Princeton Theological
Seminary and before we do that public
event I wanted to sit down with them and
talk to the two of them as artists about
how they think about the relationship
between scripture image and symbol
specifically we're going to talk a bit
about one particular icon that of the
Transfiguration but before we jump into
that particular icon I wanted to say
that I for the class I'm teaching on
Aesthetics and Christian education I
read very carefully Aiden Hart's book
Beauty spirit and matter icons in the
modern world
and what struck me about this book was
this idea that images remind us that
life with Christ is above all a
relationship between persons
and in that book Aiden just explains
that in the tradition of icons it's both
Christ's Divinity and his Humanity are
supposed to be represented so just as
the words of scripture are supposed to
reveal to us who God Is So images are
supposed to help us understand Christ's
Divinity and his Humanity
Aiden also explains in this book some
Timeless principles of liturgical art
and those principles let me see if I get
these right Aiden I don't have them
memorized but I haven't written down one
time as principle of liturgical art is
that well what I just said that God
became man the Incarnation right so
Christ showed himself as man second that
in the Transfiguration which is what
we're going to talk about today we got a
glimpse of divinized man and I want to
unpack what that means and what that
looks like in the icons of the
Transfiguration and here I think you're
taking on a big stance here
theologically when you say that matter
can be Grace bearing
um so I want to talk about that and then
you also say a fourth principle is that
human beings are fulfilled in
relationship that's why it's important
to see the faces of others and fifth
that and the fifth principle of
liturgical art is that we have what's
called The Noose a noetic faculty the
eye of the heart that we don't just know
about God With The Noose we can know God
did I get those five principles right
yeah yeah more or less yes the Noose uh
enlightened by the Holy Spirit where no
man can see God so it's almost a so
yeah I said God sees himself through the
news so it's always a Synergy a union of
the two but yes those five points are
really important well let's stay on the
news that let's stay on the news for a
second because this was a I I admit this
was a New Concept to me like the news
how do you describe the news Jonathan
I think I mean the way to understand the
the news let's say practically is to
understand that there's a there's a
capacity that humans have to
uh grasp things directly it's maybe the
best way to understand it that is
pre-discursive it's not it's not a
discursive it's not a description it's
not a it's a it's a contact that is
direct and and full uh and so we
actually we actually the news is
necessary for you to exist but there's
something about our thoughts and about
our desires and about our passions that
clouds us from being able to
to live in that space and much of the
spiritual practice you know in in the
Orthodox Church for example is there in
some ways to purify the Noose that is to
kind of still the thoughts still the
images still the word the buzzing and
the worrying so that we can enter into
the heart you know he talked about the
eye of the heart enter into the heart
and then it's in that position that all
of a sudden the news can be open to to
to Revelation to the Holy Spirit and
then you can grasp
things directly like you can see them
pierced with God but then ultimately the
the contention is that you can also you
know see the Divine Light you can enter
into God himself
wow see okay these are Big claims
um
I do actually remember distinctly my
senior year of college at Yale after I
had taken classes in psychology and
sociology and I remember walking into
church and thinking
this is a collection of rituals that
human beings say mean certain things and
other people in other points of time
have come up with rituals that they say
mean certain things and how do I know
that any of these symbols or any of
these rituals are actually anything more
than a human creation
so when I read your book now I'm still a
practicing Catholic I always have been
but as I'm teaching my students about
these images the students might be
captivated maybe their noose is being
activated they're they're having an
encounter but they're posing this
question how do I know that this image
that I'm looking at is actually
Revelation or how do I know that it's
not something from my imagination
but another thing I loved reading in
your books Aiden is that working as an
iconographer you have a way of
approaching this question about what do
we depict in art and why so that's what
I wanted to talk to you about today can
we just pick the two of you pick I
thought let's go with the
Transfiguration because that figure is
so centrally in your book Beauty spirit
and matter and I wonder if we can unpack
the event of the Transfiguration The
Encounter of the symbols the meanings
and from there just have a conversation
about how do we know when symbols come
together to reveal who God is and or
what's a human invention that's a big
question I know but let's start with the
Transfiguration
um you know what what happens to the
well the Lord just going straight from
the gospels through the gospels related
ironically the one or the three
disciples John who was there didn't
write about it
in his gospel but the other three
gospels describe it Christ takes Peter
James and John up to a high mountain it
doesn't describe what the mountain is in
the scripture is bit by tradition it's
table
and this is that he's transfigured
um and then Moses and Elijah appear with
him and they're conversing about his
coming Glory which means his crucifixion
and then dear Peter who always likes to
blurt things out says lord it's good to
be here let's make three tents
um and then the voice of the father
speaks and then Moses and eyes are going
they come back down again so that's the
basic story but there's so much packed
into that I think
that's one reason because it's so
pregnant that traditionally I don't know
how often it happens when an
iconographer is fully trained that's the
first icon they paint yeah why would
that be
says everything the Incarnation
communion but also because much of the
Theology of the of the icon you know and
the Theology of Orthodox mythicism is
related to the question of light and to
this notion of Divine Light
um and so the image of the
Transfiguration right is that is that's
what's going on in that in that image
it's about light and icons are about
light I mean especially painted icons
that's what they're dealing with
and this lies at least an orthodox
theology is God himself God doesn't
create a gift of light and give it to us
like the sun we kind of goes into the
orb of the Sun but the Sun comes to us
so the light and the warmth coming from
the Sun is sun isn't it so um so this is
the glory of God himself the Shekinah
Glory to use the Hebrew term coming to
us so
it's symbolic but it's much more than
symbolic it's actually encounter with
the Living God a lot of the Old
Testament is
Experiencing God via something Moses and
Elijah who appear with
um Christ uh they get an inkling of God
so Moses hears God's historic it sees
God in the Mount Sinai is sort of
thunder and lightning and he hears God
but doesn't actually see the Lord and
Elijah likewise he comes to the mouth of
the cave and this case God is a still
Small Voice a partial liberation
back there it Transfiguration they see
the Lord face to face incarnate Lord
face to face so it's the opposite of
symbolism yeah the symbolism leads them
to the face of God you mean it's the
opposition it's the opposite of
symbolism in the sense that that which
they're seeing is the combination of
symbolism maybe it's the best way to
understand it is our footsteps yeah and
so to the face Aiden's got it exactly
right that is you know it happens on a
mountain just like Elijah just like
Moses there's a sense in which you know
it's going up towards that space where
Heaven and Earth meet but now what is
seen there is the source of Revelation
itself it's the culmination of
Revelation at the same time and that's
one of the reasons why for example Moses
and Elijah are brought to see
right the very source of creation it's
almost you could almost say that it's a
little moment of Eternity right it's
like it's their encounter with God that
is happening the promise what they ask
God right when Moses asked he said God
show me show yourself to me and God has
said well I'll show you my back and now
he's getting the fullness of what he
asked for
and this isn't just Jonathan I Dreaming
things up if we look at the um because
people say well all this stuff how do
you know it it's in the liturgical text
the the the the the the face the icon is
bought out and put in a what's called an
analoy on the Feast of the
Transfiguration and then we hear all
these incredible hymns that are just
full of theology I have a book called
the festival name which has the
translations into English of all the
fixed feasts and it's just got London
lining and notes it's just profound
theology
so it's from these texts that we we
we're talking about really these uh
patristic texts that have been tried and
tested and always related to the
scriptures the the translation into
English uh has a notations underneath
referring to every biblical verse
referred to directly or tangentially in
the text and there's only about five
references there so they are that much
graphical text has got about five
biblical references so it's rooted in
the scriptures
so Moses died God buried him it says
Elijah went to heaven so it talks about
Moses and Elijah represent all the
living and the dead but together with
Christ and in the icon the top half you
have Christ with Moses and Elijah who
are in heaven down below you have Peter
James and John who on Earth but they're
all within
the rectangle of the icon so in fact
this is the church yeah the church
living in dead prophets all together
there all right let's let's slow down
for a minute here because I
and we we have five scripture references
but all this hymnology so you're saying
that the icon evolved both from the
scriptural references but as it was
there's also imagery or poetry let's say
in these liturgical texts that talk
about the feast Express
profound truths through poetry yeah and
it's I mean they're expressing typology
and so it's not it's not that the poet
just thought up nice images is that the
poet is versed in the Psalms this verse
in the Old Testament and that these
insights through noetic experience the
insides of seeing all of a sudden the
Transfiguration hinted at right glimmers
of it in Moses glimmers of it in
different parts of the Old Testament and
then seeing that this is all being
connected in the story of the Gospel you
know it's interesting to what extent
hymnography is actual a kind of bib the
Bible interpreting itself right
referring to these old images bringing
them back and showing you how they
connect and how all this is brought
together in the person of Christ
so one him talks about when you're a
transfigured in Christ you revealed the
original beauty of the human nature and
this refers back to a lot of the fathers
say that if I'm Syrian for example that
when it says Adam and Eve were naked
they'd been clothed before they've been
clothed in light the glory of God so
when they sinned as it whether lost that
light like if I pull out a plug or turn
off a switch these lights go out so it's
a land but yet it's not a lamp because
it's not a radiant with um through
electricity with light so this sign in
Christ
um is actually the new Adam who's put
back on the Garment of light in other
words he's not just human he he he's
shining with divinity and it's not it's
really there it's really there in the
story because this is also happening
during the Feast of Tabernacles so the
question that Peter asked it's almost a
joke in this in the story you know Peter
says can we give you a garment can we
cover this like can we make a house for
it and and Christ this is this this
moment is beyond that right this is not
this is not a this is more than a moment
that can only be held within the tent of
even the tent of the Tabernacle because
that's what it's being alluded to you
are here's the glory of God appearing to
us can we build the tent around it to
contain it and not this one right it's
so what you're saying is that that resp
that dialogue between Peter and Jesus
just that simple thing can we put a tent
around it is actually a reference yeah
we are yeah he didn't realize it
probably but no no it doesn't matter
right it's like he was just in the
moment in saying it but then when you
see it in retrospect just like the
disciples themselves at Pentecost all of
a sudden you know saw all these things
that Christ had done and how they
connected they participated in that too
let's build a few Tabernacles that
refers to the Feast of Tabernacles and
that was to remember when they lived in
the jeset and God was with them in the
desert because of course during the
daytime uh the Lord LED them forth with
a pillar of um fire a cloud at night and
a bit of a fly so the Feast of
Tabernacles was to remind that God was
with them and the desert so here
at
he's prophesying in a way peace we're
saying this is the Fulfillment yeah
that's right yeah the pillar of fire is
here before I said God himself
and then Jesus responds that no we
cannot put a tent around it is to say
this is not the symbol of the glory this
is it exactly this is the real thing
like that's this this is the real thing
yeah
before I met Jonathan In the Flesh I
might have a photograph of Jonathan
there in my living room Jonathan comes
in and he moves into the house I don't
need the photograph you know it's
redundant I've got Jonathan himself and
so there's that it's interesting because
you know I'm so bound up in the question
of symbolism but you in the Orthodox
especially in the Orthodox iconographic
tradition there's a there's some aspect
of it which is you could call
anti-symbolic in the sense that they
they move moving towards saying Christ
is the finality of these images and so
when you have Christ it's the you don't
you're not necessarily wanting to
represent him in these Shadows but you
have the thing itself it doesn't mean
that symbolism doesn't continue to exist
in this typological way there's a sense
in which Christ is the is the end of the
of the symbolic pyramid
to go back to the anecdote I shared with
you before about myself as a senior in
college
it's a little bit frightening when you
begin to realize that there's other
rituals and there's other symbols and
there's other meanings and there's other
ways of thinking about worship
because I think for me as a young person
I wanted to believe that these rituals
and these symbols truly were what I had
been told they meant and that I could
have this encounter with God because the
alternative is to say well none of this
means anything and all of this is just
made up and whatever I choose to believe
the symbols mean is what they mean and
then that's what it means to me and it's
all the same right and that wasn't very
satisfying to me either because if I
just make up the meaning then I'm not
really getting the meaning of my life
because I can just claim it to be one
thing you know but what I hear you
saying is Well there's a rich history of
symbols and symbolic thinking but
Christianity is actually claiming this
isn't just about symbols we're actually
claiming you can meet God In His glory
is that right well that would be the
point of symbols also I mean the point
of you could say that the point of
creation is so that it can meet God and
so even the even the symbols or the
symbolic hierarchy or these these These
inklings are there as a they're there to
act as a ladder that's the only thing
they're there for they're not just for
our just enjoyment and thinking about
Concepts but they're they they have to
if they don't provide levels of insight
that can bring you closer to a Divine
encounter than their
they're kind of pointless you know you
can be just turning around going around
in circles in fact the word symbol is a
combination of two Greek words Sim and
Volus which means literally to throw
together
um so the aim of a symbol is to draw us
together with the architect because
Christ so once you're together then
there's someone is fulfilled its
function you don't discard it you're
sort of thankful for that tree or
whatever that brought you closer to God
I came to believe in God's existence
through trees now I used to hide in
trees as a child playing hide and go
seek and I a sort of quiet way I can I
came to be there must be a God who made
this incredible things called trees so
when I was a Hermit living in 20 acres
Savannah planted 5 000 trees and
Thanksgiving to God
and Thanksgiving to the trees if you
like for being like Saint John the
Baptist leading me to God so it's not as
so now Matthew standards job I can spit
it out it could have makes a symbol
richer it remains there but beside
Christ instead of in eastern and western
Christianity you have these three stages
of movement toward Christ in the west
it's called um
purification illumination and Union and
in the East it tends to be called
practical theology from Praxis something
you do you've got to act and make an
effort to repent and then Fisher key
theology or natural theology perceiving
God in the nature and the created world
and then Mr key for your mystical
theology
so the first is repentance been purified
as Jonathan was saying you can't see
unless you'd get the cataracts off but
the second which is related to symbolism
is perceiving the words of God within
each created thing so this plant behind
us it didn't just come out of nothing
God spoke plant whatever it is rubber
plant and the rubber plant comes into
existence but that word that the Lord
spoke
actually keeps that in existence so when
I see the rubber plant I don't see a
plant it's a gift of love to me you know
my wedding ring is just hang of gold but
when I look at that I see my wife's love
for me and then follow these footsteps
is logo and plural these words embedded
in creation eventually come to feet and
look up and there's the face of the Lord
the logos himself we can't proceed we
can't look at the sun straight away but
gradually or I suggest until eventually
we can look at the face of the sun
himself
well
it's a kind of gradual
Ascent maybe to the face of God I would
say that the Transfiguration
is a feast in the church or a part of
the scriptures that I always struggled
to relate to it's not that long not that
many words going on there and I wasn't
until you know a little bit later in
life that there was something about the
Transfiguration that captured my
imagination and I wanted to try to
understand it more because I wanted to
believe that in the midst of these
struggles that I was having and these
issues and these problems that God still
loved me and he loved the people around
me and that things were going to be okay
and I think that this is a very visceral
human desire right that in the midst of
struggle and suffering you begin to ask
okay are is this faith that I've been
given is it really real like can I
really see God even in the midst of all
of this difficulty but I will say that
Transfiguration is not something I
remember being taught about much in
catechism or having much of a way to
think about it so when I picked up your
book as I mentioned Beauty spirit and
matter I said oh finally here's
someone's kind of unpacking the meaning
of this to me so let's let's talk a
little bit about you mentioned that what
an iconographer begins to train this is
the first one I wanted to finish the
training once they finish the training
the first one they were paid so what are
the pieces of the icon we mentioned
Moses and Elijah who what is what is it
describe the icon of the Transfiguration
like what's that what are the elements
in it I know Moses and Elijah there's
some rays there's Simon Peter no Simon
is Peter right Simon James and John
Peter James and John okay Peter James
and John there's some mountains okay so
just describe the image for me
that you've describe it well yeah so
it's there's variation in the image but
usually there's a a mountain sometimes
there's three Peaks and Christ is in the
center and then there's a glory around
him his vestments are white
um and then you have
Elijah and Moses on either side of of
Christ
below then you have in the mountain you
will have the three disciples that are
reacting to the to their Vision usually
uh James and John are kind of tumbled
over falling back you know looking away
and then uh Peter is sometimes kind of
looking towards Christ it depends on the
icon but there's a sense of what he's
gesturing towards Christ and that's when
he is asking the the question about
about the Tabernacle there are some
little details that are interesting that
that appear in the transfer aggression
for example often you'll have one or two
of the disciples losing their sandal
during the during the the they're
they're kind of being bowled over by
this this Vision
um and so those are the basic elements
of the of the Transfiguration
and from the uh the glory it can be a
circle it can be very shaped you have
Rays coming up
sometimes underneath most of the
knowledge you've got caves with with
golden some later on have the disciples
going up yeah and on one side and coming
down the other and that's quite
important um important but it has
importance that's important in the idea
also of how Revelation works right it's
like this Moses going up and bringing
something down with him and so having
that image is definitely yeah don't stop
being a state of ecstasy if you're going
to go down high school be crucified
they've got to carry the grace of God
into into the world yeah all right so in
that one image I'm hearing movement up
and down I'm hearing Old Testament I'm
hearing dialogue I mean there's a lot
happening in one image now sorry we're
gonna have to go back to basics here
what are Moses and Elijah doing there
well they they
there's several things that they're
doing one is that they are fulfilling
their their question they ask most of
them asked you know Moses asked to see
God and both of them had a partial
Revelation you know Elijah heard that
soft that quiet voice and Moses saw the
back of God as he walked by and so
they're there to see the fullness of the
glory of God that's what they're there
for they're there to kind of finalize
their their movement towards Revelation
so it's like it's what it's saying is
this is the final this is it like this
is the the the the fullness of
Revelation is being shown here you know
if there's an image without saying it
that is saying this is God it's the
Transfiguration because why are Moses
and Elijah there looking at you know
standing next to Christ in the center
who is who is revealing this Glory
completely uh and so so that's why it's
one of the reasons the law came to
remember
and Elijah it's a prophet so Christ is
the Fulfillment of the law and the
prophets the the uh not only victims
Commandments but the tent of meeting and
the Temple of all types which types of
really physical prophecies all of Christ
so this is a fulfillment of them okay so
they're beholding the glory of God in
Christ that's the Fulfillment of their
everything prophesied about all the law
everything is there okay okay and then
Jesus has invited
Peter James and John to be there
and you said that sometimes Peter has
shown looking at him yeah he's he's kind
of gesturing towards either he's looking
or sometimes he's gesturing it depends
on the the image but most of the time
he's looking towards Christ and
gesturing towards him and each of the
three postures relate to the age so the
oldest one is Peter he's looking at
Christ John is the youngest he's
probably about 19. he's the one normally
looking away James is middle age he's
sort of between the two but what's
interesting is that John is the Mystic I
mean they don't like the word but his
symbol is the ego so the eagle flies
really high but interestingly he's often
curled up and there's a lot of teaching
about the Jesus prayer when you do the
Jesus payoff and you make a circle out
of your body but you don't want your
thought to shoot out there you want to
um meet God the holy spirit in your
heart so you create a circle
um so he's seeing the Lord but but
mystically through his heart as it were
said the plenty of stories about lay and
monastic people
um experiencing the Lord through that in
a in a prayer so it's three different
ways of encountering God and they're not
um contradictory they're just different
ways so it's not that one posture is
superior to the other it's that there
are different ways of of letting the
mist of seeing this each of us are three
distinct people and each of us will
experience God in distinct ways
wow and why would the sandal be falling
off I think I have noticed that before
why is the sandal falling off yeah I
that at least for me that now this
becomes the land of speculation but I I
do think that it has to do with Saint
Gregory of nissa's vision of the the
What's called the removing of the
garments of skin so there's a there's an
image in the ascent of Moses as he goes
towards the burning bush where God says
remove your sandals for you're in a holy
place
um and say Gregory sees that as this
kind of aesthetic practice where you
remove the the passions you remove the
externals in order to enter into the
heart once again and so my I've always
when I see that sandal falling off I
feel like this is a gesture towards that
saying like this is this is the the this
removing of the of the outer garments
and moving into the holy place and it's
not that
face is bad is it it's not saying oh the
the fish is bad and anyway you can see
God has to get rid of that bad material
stuff called the flesh it's uh Jonathan
used the term passions we tend to think
of passions pejoratively but the
passions are a god-given energies but
you've got to direct them toward toward
God I'd say there'd be two other
elements as well is that you've already
alluded to Jonathan that the Lord tells
Moses to take his sandals off he's
encountered God and says Holy Ground so
this shows us that Christ is the burning
bush
a Bush's physical stuff but then it's
got this fire which doesn't consume it
so obviously the fire is is not a
created fire it must have been a Divine
fire because otherwise it would have
consumed the bush and and thirdly
if you're afraid and you're shaking your
sound might fall off
um so that's also to show that this
light is actually not just bright
physical light but this is Divine Light
it's a completely different order it's
an encounter with something that's
completely beyond anything we can
imagine in the created order so this
sort of fear and the shock and this
falling over and and the disorder of the
disciples is to emphasize that this
light is Divine Light
um and you see this in icons of the
mother of god with Christ sometimes the
sandal falls off Christ's feed and
that's because as God he knows is going
to rise die and Rise but also it's a
human he's afraid of death so the child
is shaking out of fear
um so it's a normal thing to be afraid
of death so this sort of sandal falling
off on the Vladimir icon it's called is
an indication of a film in Christ
Humanity in that case in this case it's
a fairly Christ Divinity wow and the the
supernatural nature of this lies okay so
now let's go to Christ in this image you
know as I mean mentioned to start you
say that you know one of the purpose of
icons is the real is to reveal Christ
and his humanity and in his divinity so
it would seem to me that the icon of the
Transfiguration we're clearly seeing
Christ in his divinity but are we also
seeing Christ in his Humanity what does
Christ look like in the Transfiguration
when you paint the Transfiguration
I mean he looks like it's an image of
Christ it's a recognizable image of
Christ Christ has certain
characteristics that makes us recognize
that it's him so it's definitely
representing him in his Humanity you
can't represent the Divinity of Christ
you can't represent it you can gesture
towards it you can here's a place where
you can kind of symbolize or gesture
towards Christ's Divinity and that's
what the glory that's the role that the
glory plays in this image right the Rays
of Divine Light That emanate from him
but the important thing theologically
it's the person of Christ we're
depicting yeah icons only and the the
fathers who defended icons against the
iconoclast were always affirming we're
not depicting the Divinity of Christ
we're depicting the person of Christ
um but the person of Christ is divine
he's not a human created being whom God
popped into because he was a good lad
um the person or the hypothesis to use
the Greek term of Christ is that that of
the second person of the trinity
so you're seeing this this man Jesus
Christ whose personhood is divine but as
I mentioned earlier
what is interesting is that the texts
say that he has shown us what it is to
be truly human which is to be not merely
human but to be deified to be
god-bearers so I think the miracle is
not so much the crisis transfigured but
the fact that he wasn't trans
people out it would have so in fact the
Miracles that he clothed himself as it
were to hide his divinity
and one of the aspects of the of the
mandurla or the the glory that is around
Christ is usually that it's represented
as a darkness that moves towards light
and so usually in the middle it's dark
and on the outside it's white and moving
different tones of blue towards the
towards the the light and that has to do
with this this idea that God is beyond
is beyond the description
yeah and so there's a there's a Divine
darkness is what house and Gregory
Divine Darkness yeah what is that tell
me more about that I thought I thought
you said it was about light well that's
it so there's it so it's represented in
aporia it's always represented
paradoxically so there'll be different
ways of saying it's something like a a
light so bright that it blinds you
something like that or or the idea of or
that which is beyond light even that is
the source of light so how do you how do
you figure that you know that which is
beyond description which is beyond name
which is beyond all capacity to to frame
and that is the highest aspect of of of
God in in the mystical experience and in
the descriptions even in in theological
descriptions this idea that that uh I
talked about saying Gregory of Nissa and
the Ascension of Moses and when Moses
goes up he moves into the Divine
darkness and it says that there's
Darkness covered the mountain and
there's lightning yeah you know Darkness
and Light and in the story of the
Transfiguration you get that because it
says it says a very contradictory thing
in the story it says it says they were
they were covered by a they were covered
by a cloud of light it's like what what
is that it's like two contradictory
things a cloud is something that is
shaped right it sucks right and then but
it's a cloud and it's it's light at the
same time so even in the actual text
there seems to be a kind of a Poirier
that's presented that that is implying
both light and dark at the same time
but really what we're just saying is
that is the unknowable no unnerability
of God
um in Orthodox theology we discern
distinguish between the essence of God
which even in the age to come is
unknowable and the energies of God it's
rather unfortunate translation but
basically it's it's the living person or
God
in his nobleness you know like if I said
I've I've known you for two years I know
you're entirely
you'll be a bit offended by that even if
I knew for two thousand years Margarita
will always be unknowable to some extent
you know your each of us is created in
God's image so each have asked is
Eternal in the sense that we never
entirely know I mean both of us are
married we're married but we know we're
never going to know our spouse in their
entirety so this is a noble Essence in a
way and if this is true of humanity
surely it's true of God
from our point of view it's not darkness
and God himself but we can know we're
getting closer to knowing you can know
your oh yeah of course yeah and
gregorithia whom Jonathan's referred to
a lot he he uses the term from glory to
glory a lot of course at Saint Paul's
town that even in the ages can we if
we're growing closer to God okay yeah
it's an eternal message uh Journey right
right so now
in the Transfiguration Christ is filled
with light and I believe you've told me
Aiden that also it's important to depict
the garments are also filled with light
it's not just his face it's not just the
Rays emanating out from his noose maybe
but his His Garment is transfigured
that's what the scriptures say it's
saying that the face shines with that
but although all three gospels talk
about the garments they do oh my God
this is I don't know if you want to
speak to this is one of my favorite
subjects yeah yeah I mean it's just the
clothes we wear in they're just
inanimate aren't they they're not
personable they're just woven linen but
this inanimate matter participates in
this uncreated Glory so that this is and
in Greek one of the terms used for what
we now call nature rather sadly that
this call of the created World
um is cosmos
uh the the God God created the cosmos
and Cosmos in Greek means adornment
Cosmetics comes from that so Christ's
Cosmos Christ garment
is really the whole of the created World
which is wrapped around himself and is
filled with light again
so Maximus to Confessor talks a lot
about this that each stage of Christ
he's Gathering something which had been
discarded by the Fall Adam and Eve
discarded creation by not
um giving thanks it just sort of became
dead then when you if I take this
garment off it just becomes dead it just
flops when it's on me it takes on my
form it actually participates in my
personhood so really what's happening in
the Transfiguration is that the person
of God who's taken on our Humanity the
off before so it's the second Adam is
transfigured but through the second Adam
who's like a a priest between
the Creator and the rest of creation the
whole of the cosmos participates in his
Transfiguration and Saint Paul talks
about this in Romans 8 the horde of
creation sort of groaning waiting for
the Redemption of the children of God
because it too then will be filled with
Glory
all of creation but I mean are my
clothes part of creation yeah of course
they are
but I thought but it's very it's there's
a very there's a very deep understanding
of
even in terms of the story of the Fall
you know garments are very important
because Adam and Eve are clothed in
glory right that's the way that at least
San Ephraim presented in some of many of
the church fathers and then in the fall
is when they kind of see themselves as
naked as lacking
and then they they feel like they have
to add something to themselves and so
these dead garments of skin get added to
them but that doesn't stop there it
becomes also civilization right so Cain
goes further down into the fall and he
builds this city and he builds these
walls and technology and these weapons
and the the idea is that that is somehow
a reaction or it's a movement of the
Fall that's going deeper and deeper down
into into basically going all the way to
the flood in the biblical narrative and
the surprise of Christ is that he fills
all of that with light so the final
image let's say of the Transfiguration
is the Heavenly Jerusalem which is now
it's like now it's really just the
entire world that is filled with Glory
but the hint of that or the the promise
of that is exactly like Aiden said is
that this garment that Christ wore is
now no longer let's say a dead Garment
of skin but is now
feel like it's full of the of the very
Glory by participation in the person of
Christ because the Garment takes on the
form of the person wearing it
and it's only friends figure because
it's part part of them it's not him but
it sort of takes on his image I said
well so what you're saying I think Aiden
has really profound theological
implications that
the person of Christ has his garments
are part of the person of Christ is that
what I hear you say um distinct but yes
like I had to put it or they helped to
reveal the person yeah yeah I mean the
whole of creation
is in God's image I mean we we are
persons with freedom so we're more in
the image of God but everything in in
creation even to a rock
it's a symbol reflects some aspect of
God's life so in fact the whole of
creation was created as a temple for us
to worship God let him talk much about
this you're talking about how do we know
the rituals have significance if it's
true worship it should reflect Heavenly
worship this is why God had revealed to
Moses exactly how to build the tins of
meeting and exactly how to
uh moral the year liturgically because
it wasn't this man's invention dreaming
it up he had to reflect had to be an
icon of heavenly worship
um so the whole creation was created by
God as a temple for us to worship him in
and it affected uh the truth of who God
is
okay so in some ways
I mean because we believe that human
beings are created in the image of God
and my clothes aren't created in the
image of God but yet they somehow
reflect God's glory which is different
their take on your shape and your image
of God say that they're that obviously a
lower image of God than you are because
they're just inanimate
um but you could understand I mean if
you want a simple example that's not
that doesn't because I see it's kind of
confusing you but you can you can
imagine that let's say in in when you go
to you go to church and then you have a
chalice right it's like you hear that
this is kind of a child it's like we
have Cubs we have things but then all of
a sudden there's this possibility of
taking something which we use in common
day life and then bringing it into
service and bringing it into worship
then it participates in this movement
towards God and so you know so in some
ways you could say that for let's say
this it's a Liturgical Movement but
think about it in terms of what the
promise is that this will fill the whole
world right that is what the promises
that the the reason for creation is that
it can be theophanic that it can be a
place where God reveals himself I mean
in some ways that's the reason for
creation without that why did God create
the world like God created the world out
of this it's in the way of him
trying to get in the way of it okay so
all of creation from you know plants and
trees and clothing can participate in
the glory of God is that well God
created it but it says in Hebrews that
Bobby word of his power all things
sustained so God just didn't create and
then he walks away and that thing has
its own God remains in that and gives it
life so Bishop callistos whereas is that
Christians aren't pantheists but they
are panintheists you know goddess and
everything sustaining it this is the
meaning of the logoy the words I mean
it's the second stage of the spiritual
life is to discern see hear the words of
God within each created thing it was a
highlight you're obviously an animal is
is high enough they're hierarchy than a
stone but nonetheless everything in its
own way is an image of reflection uh it
takes on some element of God's form
inverted Karma so that means that the
word monocot means one who is alone
and all of us call to be monarchy
monastics in the sense that wherever I
look if I look at Jonathan look at you
look at look at look at a tree I'm
seeing God in that you're not God but I
see God coming through you so everything
becomes iconographic so
um and this is I think the essence of
the Fall that I think it's Ephraim who
suggests that the tree of knowledge God
and Evil it's the whole created world
and it will become knowledge of good for
Adam and Eve I.E art if we give thanks
for it so when you give thanks
you see the person The Giver in that
gift
if I just grab that gift and turn my
back then it becomes knowledge of evil
becomes dead for you
so this is why the Eucharist I think
it's wonderful but the Central Christian
Act is the Eucharist to give thanks that
everything then is a means to be holding
the Lord so then we're all living like
monarchy monastics and that we're living
alone with God in fact the whole
universe is gathered in so with our look
is the Lord
well I like the word I've been teaching
this class on the Virgin Mary and I like
the verb kind of gathering and it sounds
like from what you were saying a moment
ago Jonathan that the Transfiguration of
the clothing the matter
were Were Meant to gather all of the
creation of God and sort of Bring It
Back give thanks kind of you know bring
it back to God so all of these things
God created at this point in time but
they're meant to be gathered and brought
back in a and then therefore thereby
participate in this in this Glory see
that did help me right because as a as a
young person well what's the alternative
to that well you use things and you do
things but it's completely unrelated to
your March towards God right you just go
towards God in your head but all these
things that you're interacting with
nature objects Etc that's sort of
Superfluous to the spiritual journey and
what I hear you saying is no no no all
of those things are part of our
spiritual journey they don't have a soul
they don't have a noose but we're meant
to gather we're meant to to Steward and
to appreciate the presence the creation
of God and all of matter and and Steward
that gather it bring it back to him and
that to me was very moving to think that
that's a that's a beautiful way to think
about life rather than
um using and throwing away or consuming
just for pleasure that all of these
things can can come together so I guess
in the time that we have left I wondered
if you know if you could share with me
what this Feast means to you or what the
Transfiguration means to you I mean was
there a moment in time when you asked
yourself like what really is the meaning
of the Transfiguration what does this
look like in my life why do I need to to
meditate on this or to ponder this
particular feast
I mean I
I think that there Christ in the the
gospels there are moments in his story
and each moment reveals an aspect of the
mystery that Christ is uh you know and
so to me the the the trans I see in some
way the Transfiguration the crucifixion
is almost kind of standing in contrast
with each other
there's here's this moment of where
Christ is revealed in his divinity
through a kind of Glory through a you
know really using all the symbolism of
the Old Testament all the symbolism of
the of the glory of God the Shekinah all
these all this this imagery is brought
there
um and then you have this other
contrasting images where the glory of
God the glory of Christ is actually
being shown on the cross as well but in
a very strange inverted and and hidden
way
um and so to me you know I I love that I
like there's something about have it
holding those two stories in tension
which I think is important for us
you know in terms of even in terms of
the liturgical artists for example and
so we we understand that the beauty of
the church right the beauty of all the
things that we make you know the the
frescoes the mosaics all of this is in
some ways
a participation in the in the in the
Transfiguration uh and so and that we're
called to kind of hold these two things
in tension you know one which is the
self-sacrifice one which is the the
helping the poor to care for those in
need to to kind of give ourselves to
empty ourselves for others but then
there's also the possibility and the
importance of celebrating that glorious
aspect we're all creation comes together
and celebrates God uh you know and so so
so to me the image of the
Transfiguration as a as an artist is is
in some ways a Guiding Light to say like
no there is this possibility of of
participating in that and and like you
said Gathering the elements Gathering
bits of wood bits of gold bits of stone
and and being able to to to hopefully
offer something up so that it
participates in that process oh that's
beautiful John and let me see if I heard
what you're saying that for you and your
vocation is to be a liturgical artist
you make sculptures you do design you
iconographic that the image of the
Transfiguration the meaning of the Feast
of the Transfiguration in some ways is
like it gives meaning to your vocation
or gives inspiration that what you're
doing as an icon Carver an iconographer
you're taking created material and
you're working with it and putting it
together in ways that participate even
further in the glory of God and it gives
meaning is that you hope someone's the
anchor it's it's it's part of the anchor
of what makes a liturgical artist do
what they do at least for me is this
idea of kind of stewarding and Gathering
the materials and then creating an image
that's kind of bringing creation back to
God in an act of Thanksgiving I liked
very much what you said that part of our
calling as people of faith is to serve
the poor and to care for the needy but
we're also called to to gather and to
co-create with God and to make beautiful
things that give Glory that that
celebrate
celebrate yeah that lead us into this
place of rejoicing and celebrating that
God's presence has come into the world
and therefore matter has been can be
Sanctified and can be gathered and
brought back
I think that goes beyond liturgical
artists right for any kind of vocation
for anyone working in the world doing
anything like this is so inspiring
because otherwise you know then your
faith and your work are just completely
separate from each other so that's
that's a very inspiring message thank
you what about for you Aiden
uh as you're talking I was thinking
perhaps there are three things face
community and matter I think I sort of
nominally raised an Anglican but never
really had a conscious Faith but when I
was 15
um I had a conversion experience as this
man was speaking about the faith I saw a
face full of light but also they were
there was a crowd behind there were
people behind and this is what converted
me so it was the face of Christ but also
it wasn't just him isolated and that
sort of entered my heart and I've sort
of measured everything against that in a
way so when I encountered the
Transfiguration icon there you have it
the face of Christ but not alone
um but being an artist I started off as
a Baptist which I really loved I got to
know the scripture as well but I felt
matters hasn't really got a place here
the material world it sort of does not
mentioned really so my journey kept
going uh and and when I discovered the
icon tradition and the Orthodox
affirmation of the material world when I
saw the Transfiguration icon and started
reading about the theology I realized ah
no I've got the face of Christ got the
community of the church here's Mata
transfigured you were describing this
process of of taking
god-given matter up and making it even
more articulate in the worship of God
that artistic process here it's all in
the Transfiguration icon so that's why
the idea of Christ Garmin being Cosmos
means a lot so much to me the garments
aren't just raw Flags someone has taken
the flanks span it woven it so here this
idea of man as prophet
priest and King and I understand
kingship is like an artist like
Jonathan's got to be master of his
stereotype and he's carving it but he's
not master to crush it and grind it he's
master of it to raise that hunk of
inanimate Stone to become the face of
Christ so kingship to me is the kingship
of an artist to to make creation more
articulate and the praise of God so
that's what the transformation says for
me that's very inspiring and I know
we'll hear more from you on priest
prophet and King in your lecture
tomorrow at the pts and Scholar
Foundation conference and you know
Jonathan I wanted I wondered if you
could just give us a few minutes uh just
a few words really what are you speaking
about tomorrow at the scholarship
friends like pts well actually it has a
little bit to do with what we're saying
you know there's something about uh
especially modern especially
Contemporary Art there's a sense in
which the artist is there to question
right the artist is there to to to poke
at the system and to to uh to try to
break you know the structures that are
are there and what I want to explore
tomorrow is how traditional art and how
especially liturgical art is in some
ways there to celebrate and to bring
together and to kind of build identities
and so we're going to look at that the
dangers of that also there are dangers
in that and so we're going to try to
look at in scripture and how it all it
all kind of comes together in the person
of Christ like most stories so that's
great
great and you know as I mentioned at the
start uh The Scholar foundation's
mission is to restore culture through
liberal arts education Beauty and
worship and this event that we that I've
put together this weekend is going to
bring together artists with Educators
with Scholars to experience the beauty
of the campus here at Princeton
Theological Seminary the University
Chapel Sacred Music and I wondered if
you could comment on what was it that
attracted you to be a part of Scholar's
Mission what do you find about Scholar's
mission that made you interested in
being a part of this
I mean you know I think the world is
hungry for exactly the things you
mentioned you know people are are heavy
because the world is quite ugly
especially in America in Europe you have
more luck than we do we have more chance
than we do you know the the suburbs this
plastic World in which we live and also
this world of consuming I think it it in
some ways it's sad but it also is a kind
of a hunger and people
are looking for meaning and looking for
beauty and so if we can help people move
in that direction it's wonderful great
well I would encourage everybody
watching this to look at Aiden Hart's
website Aiden heart icons they're
beautiful images wonderful essays please
do check out his books beauty matter in
the sacred also his Book Festival icons
which was really easy Spirit matter
Beauty Spirit matter excuse me Beauty
Spirit matter thank you
um his Book Festival icons was released
just in 2022 is that right and his book
on
um drawing icons are techniques of Icon
and wall painting techniques of Icon and
wallpapers the best it's the best book
on on painting icons that exist I mean I
think it's pretty unanimous so if you're
interested in icons that book is the
book to get